咱们再啰嗦几句啊，再讲点儿。因为这个这个我说嘛，这个我就上这个课确实有很多地方我考虑的不周到，是因为我共情你们的想法的时候啊，有时候不能供的那么准。
有些地方我感觉一跳而过了。
可能你们在那就就就迷惑了就迷惑了。
然后这个这个我我一下想起来这个这个咱们这节课。
上节课我讲的这个B故事这里。
我说根据这个节拍表。
我们在第二部分城这里。
在30分钟左右。
要开始。
B故事的起点。
我提了这么一下，我也说了，B护事往往是。
呃，感情线啊。
B故事是人物湖光的起点，对吧？我上节课说了，然后有时候也是感情线的起点。
呃，我感觉同学们肯定在这里有迷惑的。
我把这里详细跟大家说一下，好吧，就什么叫B故事？什么叫A故事？咱们得先说，对吧？
在有些教材里面，他们把AB故事直接翻译成主线故事和副线故事。
这种方法呢也不能说人家说的不对，但是就是没有考虑到初学者的感受。
初学者就会以为奥那A故事呃主线故事是主要的事儿。副线故事呢是次要的事儿，它就容易把你。
把你带到那个沟里去了，你就会那么理解去了。
那么理解是不对的啊，就是他翻译成这样是没毛病，但是有歧义。
所以你这么去理解吧？啥叫A故事？啥叫B故事啊？这里不是B故事起点吗？我们说一下啥是A故事。
A故事你可以理解为。
确实是主线故事，但你可以理解为主角经历的那些事情。
就是他经历的这些主要的事情，他要做的那些事情，他是一个。
主角经理的那些事儿。
然后呢。
或者是说外在的。
哎写在这看不见了是吧？外在的一些事情，你这么去理解。
然后B故事呢B故事是我们这个角色啊，他内心经历的这个历程。
我不是说庇护室是人物湖光吗？人物弧线的起点。
这么理解好理解吧，就是说A股市是外在实际上办的那些事儿。
B故事是内心的成长，内心的历程。
起点终点。
你这么去理解，所以它其实不是主要和次要的关系，是外在和内在的关系。
明白吗？
嗯。
所以A故事一般来说，那你说它是主线，也可以呃这么理解，对吧？你你就是他经历的这些事情完成的这些事情嘛。
然后庇护时就是他内心的一步一步的成长，一步一步的蜕变。
成为了一个。
更好的更完整。他原文上写的是成为了就主角呃内在的。
逐步完整。
就是书上这么翻，但是你可以就简单理解为就是be a better man嘛。
对吧主角成长了吗？比比better了。
这就是A故事和B故事。
这就是所谓的。
AB故事。
为什么有些地方喜欢把ABAB故事拎出来说呢？是因为AB故事在有时候它是单写的，就有些编剧是习惯单写的。
因为咱们不管是拉大纲，拉这个八要素啊，体成转合，然后这个十序列十物节拍，你不管怎么拉，其实你表你都是跟着A走的。
就这其实都是你的A故事，你是不太会。我当然跟大家说过，我说你的角色要在这个过程中实现人物胡荒，实践成长。但是大家不会单去写它，然后呢，有时候就会有点忽略它，甚至不太完整。所以在有的创作。
理念里面。
人家是把B故事单写的。
就是拉一个表格，哎，这条线上主角都经历了什么？
B这条线上主角又都经历了什么，对吧？他内心第一次被触动，第一次被点燃，然后第一次被那个感情所融化，然后又是因为什么刺激，就是说他的内心的成长历程打点，人家也给你写出来的，是有这种创作方法。
好吧，然后对应这个AB故事，我再给大家讲一个这这个你可能会经常会遇到的。
一个一个所谓的概念。
在A这件事情上做的事情。
他们一般称之为want。
然后在B这件事情上。
主角的所需要的东西一般称之为need。
所以在有的呃这个理论里面。
会把这个角色的want和 need的单独剖析一下。
忘的是什么？
w就是主角的外部需求。
表面上他的那个需求，他以为自己想要什么。
他就是w。
逆的是什么？逆的是需要，want是想要嘛？
逆的是需要？
want是外在欲望。
想要嘛逆的是内在需求，就你实际缺啥。
我们说小蝌蚪找妈妈给大家举过这个例子，小蝌蚪找妈妈。
小蝌蚪外在的欲望是我要找到我妈妈。
啊。
他不知道自己的身世，不知道自己是个啥。然后呢，觉得别人都欺负我，孤立我，我做为一个孤儿，对吧？我要找到我妈妈，我外在的需求，就小蝌蚪外在的需求是我要找我妈。
对吧他们都欺负我。
外在的欲望啊是找到他妈，但是你内在的需求是什么呢？
内在的需求是你要强大起来，你要坚强起来，你要be a better蝌蚪，人家就不欺负你了。
对不对？人家欺负你，孤立你，你没有存在感，没有朋友。
我是。
因为你没有妈。
你找不找妈。
是你外在，你认为你忘他的。
其实你内在啊，你就逼着掰天蝌蚪就行了。
这就是里面的区别。
所以want是对应A故事的。
你因为啥办的A这些事儿是是实是want。然后呢，你的内心旅程是逆的，所以want和逆是对应AB故事的。大家记住会有时候会有一些理论里面会提到这个。
所以我们说这个。
AB故事啊，我再给大家举几个例子啊，就是基本上所有的电影的AB故事都是比较清晰的，特别是商业片来说都是比较清晰的。
举什么例子？咱咱们就举咱们课上看过的片子。
这样的话大家都比较熟悉。
小蝌蚪找妈妈。
咱们呃讲过后看过的片子嘛，就咱们这个课上咱们同学都熟悉的片子，来小蝌蚪找妈妈。
他的外在需求，它的外在的旺差。
就是对吧我是个谁，我要知道我身世，对吧？我我只要找到我妈怎么着怎么着，这就是他驱在他外在A故事主驱驱使他踏上A这个旅程的w嘛。
但他实际的需要是什么呢？
实际的需要可能在每一版里不一样，但是实际的需要基本上都是比2better可。
你要自己强大起来呀。
对不对？你你你别人不不那个那个你没有存在感，没感觉自己没有价值，不知道自己是个啥，有可能是你不够勇敢。
有可能是你不够自信，有可能是你不够关心别人，对吧？你成天叽歪我是孤儿，我是孤儿，我妹吗？一是你自己性格不好，人家才不跟你做朋友的，不是因为你没有骂人家不跟你做朋友，是因为你性格不好。
对吧觉得自己出身不好，就在那儿天天叽歪，天天那那那个性格不好呀。但是他在旅程中虽然感觉我是我去找我妈，我去找我妈这个A这个旅程是这样，但是在B里面，对吧？在这个B线上。
他实际的需求。
他也在一步一步做，只是他不知道。
他在不经意间完整了自己。
呃呃，强大的自己，对吧？首先他原本很怕黑，但是独自上路之后。
怕黑这件事情你得。
客服吧。
他原本不愿意跟别人说话。
因为他觉得别人别人瞧不起自己呃。
所以他才没有朋友。但是在路上这个过程中，他要有朋友吗？
他要有有伙伴吧，他要开始与人真诚的交流吧，否则你一个人怎么能扛下这些所有的事儿呢？然后还有。
他原本这个这个呃从来没有管过闲事儿。
对吧他一一直觉得那每个人都有妈各找各妈。
对吧凭什么我。
他去从来不管闲事，然后他在这个路上呢，又。
帮助了人。
参与到别人的事情当中去了，去评事儿去了。在经过某个历程的时候，越来越自信，越来越勇敢，越来越。
成为了一个更好的蝌蚪，更值得交的朋友。然后他就发现哎呀，我有朋友了。
我虽然没有找到我妈，但是我有价值，有朋友。
也挺好的，这就是B故事。也就是说B故事你这些打点。
也是寄托在A股市经历的那些事上。
A股事那些事儿。
对吧，但是你B故室这里也要单拉一条线，你知道哪些事儿是为B服务的。
哪些事是既服务A又服务B。
然后你的臂也是完整的，也就是你有个完整的人物内心的历程。
人物的弧光忽现就是指这个好吧。
这就是所谓的AB故事望腾义的。还有我们说。
咱们还讲过那个吗？
在课程早期的时候，那个想要殉职的警察。
对不对？
忘了是什么了？
他的旺他是照顾他女儿。
对吧他他他说我我要照顾我女儿，我们女儿不给我照顾那个那个那个那个我女儿不搭理我离婚，因为我没钱，我妈是他就认为这些问题，然后呢，他就着着重开始解决钱的问题。所以他想诈骗那个抚恤金，想寻死各种。
这就是他A故事的。
外在的那个。但是我们说那个故事，他开始哎学死之后，他开始就是变得想学死之后，他开始就是不怕死了吗？就开始在工作中立功。
然后呢，就开始因为立了功之后，同事觉得哎这个人还蛮勇敢。然后呢。
社会地位也在提升，职位也在提升，人呢也变得开始本来胡子拉碴的，现在感觉自己哎突然领导也重视我了，对吧？外形也要搞起来了。
生活态度也搞起来了，以前天天吃外卖，现在呢哎觉得哎我烧烧饭吧，对吧？才发现自己已经十几年没烧饭了。
然后在，开始的时候，自己的片区有小流氓，有些违法行为，他都放任。现在因为自己哎感觉自己哎，我上次那个银行大劫案我都给搞定了，那这些人我要管一管了。
他在不经意间。
他的庇估是。
也是很完整的。
也经历了内心的历程，也成为了一个更好的男人，更好的警察，更好的父亲。
最后他的女儿搭理他了。
并不是因为他A故事上。
所经历的那些事情。
他办的那些虚假的事情，他想要去诈骗抚恤金这件事情是因为他逼迫使这条线。
所以我们说他的ant是这个这个这个它外在的趋势，它的欲望是。
赢得女儿的爱，照顾好女儿，对吧？然后他A故使的w他是我我要诈骗抚恤金就能赢得我的女儿。但实际上他需要的是什么？
你想要赢得你女儿，你最需要是当个好爹。
对吧当个好爹。
这个这这。
昨天晚上直播的时候，我给大家看的那个我给大家看的那个片子，回到17岁不也一样吗？回到17岁，我们说那个牵着了演的那个父亲，他他他。
他他他怎么着来着，他呃他失去了呃老婆，失去了儿子和女儿的爱，眼看要失去整个家庭，对吧？他。
全失去了。
等于他想把这件事情搞回来，他想赢回家庭。
他想赢回家庭的爱，是他的欲望。
然后呢，他在A故事里面的他的望道是什么？
他在A故事里面w就是我要。
打篮球赢奖学金牛逼起来，成为一个大明星上好的大学。他本来以为自己没上大学，是自己人生最大的遗憾嘛。
而且怨他老婆嘛。
然后呢。
他在A故事上就拼命的打球赢奖学金，然后这个而且还利用这一点，利用这个自己又能回到17岁这一点想想赢回。
想想想想利用这个优势啊，利用自己穿越回去这个优势想把。
老婆女儿儿子都搞回来，因为人家又不知道他是谁，他就像个间谍一样，想把大家都搞回来，对吧？这就是A股上经历的事情。
但是B故事呢。
你仔细去看B故史。
他的。
历程我们说跟。
殉职的警察一样，他的庇护是他需要的是什么？需要是做一个好丈夫，做一个好父亲就可以了。
比要betterman就可以了。你去看B股时，他一步一步打点，打的非常的完整细微。
第一次发现。
女儿的。
事情第一次跟儿子谈心。
第一次认真的看他老婆收拾的院子，他老婆是个园艺师呀，最大的理想就是我要把后院装饰的什么什么，对吧？开场就说了，但是他。
不care，他觉得这算什么，但是他。
在B护室里面发现了哇。
愣住了，直接真的好美啊。
你真的很有才，你确实非常适合。
做原意识就是。
他在B故事里面。
别白太慢了。
打点打的非常的完整。
精巧。
你仔细再去看B故事。所以说AB故事啊，我们往往不管是我们写也好，看也好。
我们关注的都是A，其实是容易把B给忽略掉的。
回到17岁是吧？也是这样。
那我们。
那我们还看过什么片子？
定制伴郎。
定制版郎。
定制吧拿来。
这个这个一个这个这个犹太小胖子要结婚，但是他没有朋友，怕这个新娘瞧不起他。因为新娘是一个交际花呀，就是那种fion girl，对吧？就是那种。
soocal的 girl，然后呢，他呢自己是个闷包，没有一个朋友，从小是个书呆子。然后父母还呃很早就离开了，等于是这么一个小胖子，他就是怕他这个媳妇儿马上要结婚的这个这个这个未婚妻瞧不起他。然后呢听说有外面也可以有顾伴郎。
这个业务，然后就花钱雇了一个。
一组半郎，其中有一个领头的是那个黑人凯文哈特。然后嘞。
解决他没有朋友。
的尴尬。
对吧解决他没有朋友的尴尬。
这就是。
视角人物是这个小胖子嘛。
男一我们可以说他是双男主啊，但是凯伐哈特的戏份肯定是稍稍次予他的双男主这个。
这个这个这个小棒子。
来，我们说。
他的A故事行动线是什么？
故人假装自己的伴郎。
别穿帮，好好结婚，雇一个人混过去，这是他A故事上所有的外在的行动吧？
这是他的w。
外在的需求啊。
外在的欲呃这个这个外在的欲望呀。
那你说他的内在需求是什么？
内在需求是什么？
太简单不过了，你交个朋友嘛？
对不对啊？你去交个朋友嘛。
折腾那么半天，费那么大劲，骗那么多人，还花那么多钱。
你的逆的你的真实的逆的。
你去交一个朋友嘛，交一个好朋友嘛。
是不是啊？
所以你看它慢慢的一步一步的。
你去看仔细去看B股时的打点，那个小胖子跟凯伦哈特两个人交朋友这段友情。
我们说凯罗哈特就是那个被雇佣的伴郎。